[Music]
good morning ladies good morning so the
thing that I realized for people that
are not realizing who are watching this
interview right now it's 5:00 in the
morning and you guys are wide awake and
joking it's it's very early in the
morning here in Toronto and you guys
what flew in yesterday I did yeah yeah
and I flew in the day before yesterday
okay but you're both looking ahead of
where we are right now
yes we're actually in the future we're
traveling back actually I have a lot of
things I want to talk to you about but
the only reason I get to the only reason
Collider gets to be here at the Toronto
Film Festival is because the great
sponsors I want to give a huge thank you
to Nordstrom Canada for being an awesome
sponsor and allowing us to cover movies
like yours so jumping right on in first
of all a great job on the movie it is do
you find it is easier to I don't know if
a movie like this it's so much harder in
America to make films like this now
because everything is more escapist fare
and it's harder and harder to get
financing to tell stories like this how
was it for you guys - it was it tough to
get this film off the ground I think
we're very blessed to live in a country
that supports the Arts from the
government so of course there's a lot of
room for experiments and to make more
extreme stories or more provocative
stories so we did work on it for a long
time but that was also because we wanted
to be to the script to be like really
good before we started and because we
I'm a first time director and this is
our very first movie that we also
co-produced as a company so that's why
but I think the country has a lot of
money for arts and I think that is
beautiful and very important although
this of course as we say was made for an
apple and an egg so it was a low-budget
film it's not like it's 50 million
obviously in it we shot it in 23 days
okay first of all that's crazy and
amazing but you know something I
realized that like most of the people
watching the interview right now will
not have seen it yet so how have you
been describing the friends the film to
friends and family you're a good picture
I just keep you very short it's about
like a prison and in the prison works a
psychotherapist who's very experienced
and she then falls in love so to say
with the criminal that she's treating
and he is a sex offender okay it's one
of it that's a good description it's
almost like you've practiced that that I
did one of the things that I really
enjoyed about the film is that the
audience is not given any easy answers
but you are allowed as an audience
member you're wondering what's going on
it's provoking you making you think talk
a little bit about the that aspect of
the film and and putting that in the
script well that's exactly what we were
after I think well would you keep saying
that we started the film with a question
not so much with the with a statement
but you can say bit more about that
maybe well I think when I heard about
this story because it's actually based
on true events as I saw this - the first
time I ever thought of the idea was when
I saw a news program where and they had
an item on which was called love in
prison so it was about relationships
like this and so then I was like how is
it possible that someone who studied you
know to be a therapist who knows more
than anybody else in the world what kind
of dangers there are in treating these
people how manipulative they can be and
still she falls for him and I think in a
smaller way you could say like why do we
eat chocolates like ten bars of
chocolate when we are said why do we
look at our phone all day when we
shouldn't why do we smoke why do we you
know take drugs why do we constantly do
stuff that we know is destructive and
still we do it and of course this story
is very extreme but I think everybody
can relate to addiction and toxic
behavior a hundred percent no I mean a
hundred percent you know it's yours well
it's your attic I think I think like you
guys coffee I also am a big fan of red
wine yeah I get it I get it
yeah no we're all driven so weird it's
and that fascinates us and and that's
right and I also Paul Verhoeven that we
both worked with when we were acting in
his film black book he always said to me
if you want to make a movie because I
always had that dream say you have to
have a question a real real real
question and so I think this was our
question like why why why why why does
she do this that's
interesting first of all I have to say
that I'm a big fan of your work with
Paul I wish I Paul listen Paul's I'm a
big he has made some movies that I
absolutely adore and so I think he's a
very talented filmmaker anyway
jumping into your guys is again so you
obviously don't you have no matter what
movie you're making you never have
enough time you never have enough money
on any film but so you're getting ready
to start filming this thing what are you
most nervous to be able to pull off with
the time and money you have well the
time and money was not I mean as an
actor I was just basically mostly
focusing on how do I get this how do i
how do I make this story compelling
without people sort of rejecting that
the subject because how can i lure them
in even though the character is not per
se sympathetic immediately so that was a
challenge for me and and I really like
that that it wasn't just you know it
wasn't it wasn't presented on a plate
like this is if you know a fun
happy-go-lucky girl next door a fun fun
show you know you have to work and and I
and I love that and and and working
together was just for me a dream because
I felt very safe very very inspired
every day I felt like she completely
gets me she trusts my instincts I trust
her instincts so hence the title so yeah
that was more my focus I mean of course
I'm co-producing as well but I was more
focused on the acting to be honest in
this sure which was a good thing now for
me I think because we had such a short
amount of shooting days and very limited
budgets which we both really wanted also
because we thought that's the best way
to learn because as you said no matter
what happens you will always not have
enough money just so but I think I
prepared myself almost like a military
person you know so in order to also
because they're both like such great
actors I mean the male lead is played by
Marwan Quezada he's also like a big star
and so I really I I wanted to be able to
answer any
chin that they would have and also for
myself because it was my first film and
I never went to film school I just
prepared like crazy for it in order to
be like free together with them on the
set and be intuitive on the set because
we did our homework so well I'm always
actually I'm curious you guys seem like
you get along so great you seem like
BFFs what was the last like what was the
last real fight you two had and over
what have you had a real fight and what
did you making the movie definitely not
during the movie I think we were just
like almost melting into each other it
was like yeah it was a really magical
experience for me and also you never
know whether we you're gonna you're
gonna feel uncomfortable or whether it's
weird for him/her to tell me what to do
and but it was never liked it never felt
like there was a hierarchy you in any
way so your single last big fight was
over where you went to lunch no we we
are a little bit oily conflicts with
textures oh yeah oh it's over
we no it's fine in the end but yeah one
of the things that I loved talking about
is the editing process because that's
the final rewrite so I'm curious you get
in the editing room you're looking at
all your footage
what are you super excited about and
what are you absolutely terrified about
because it was totally the first time
for me to experience this whole process
I was really happy with for instance
there was one scene where she was
dancing on her own which I thought it
was just like a short movie by itself in
her apartment and I was so in love with
it but we had to let it go in the end
because it was just not helping the
story and moments like that I felt were
very emotional where you really have to
let go of some of the material that I
still think and other scenes as well
there were actually a lot of I'm really
a fan of dance so I would I wanted to
make a lot of scenes in the movie where
people started to dance so I had more of
these scenes and I almost all had to cut
all of them because it was just not it
didn't fit into the story director's cut
yeah and I had a great editor by the way
the editor who also works with Paul of
course so that was I mean it was great
to have a teacher like that like
somebody who knows everything but yet I
had to be careful to also really Mae
get into what we wanted it to be like
you know and not and not be too much
influenced by everybody's experience
100%
have you seen ex machina no okay
I've heard about it right there's a
there's a very famous gif of Oscar Isaac
dancing and it's gone it's very like a
viral gif of him doing like this damn
need to see that you do because I was
going to say that after that dancing
which went viral it's very hard to put
dancing in movies because you have to
compete with Oscar Isaac in ex machina
oh this already sounds beautiful to me
I'm gonna like it meets UT Google that
and way it'll come up immediately ex
machina Oscar Isaac something so anyway
so you I forget what the final length of
the movie is but how long was your first
cut compared to what people are gonna
see oh yeah it was it was much much
longer I think it was like 45 minutes
longer something was really long it was
really long and but I already because
everybody warned me for the first time
you see your move you have even on
YouTube you can see all these really
famous directors talk about that like
okay so when you see the first caught
you're gonna be so depressed you're
gonna I didn't have that at all because
I was not that I was proud of myself at
all because I still saw like oh my god
how are we gonna do this but because I
was so impressed by what the two of them
did because I think what they did is so
embarrassing so vulnerable so they went
into places that are so hidden within
yourself so I think the performances are
just I mean I can only like I almost
start to cry what when I talk about it
no I really think they're both like I
they feel like they're my children you
know later because this is what happens
when you were directing because you're
looking at them for like a year
constantly so it's just like they're
your children blood but they are both
just my heroes oh my last question for
you we're about to switch what was the
last thing you cut out before the film
got locked so the last sequence the
thing that almost made it in the movie
the thing that happens was then there's
I'm gonna like tell this because I don't
care this was like there's one scene
where she goes to her she's sleeping she
goes to the bathroom she returns and she
suddenly a huge black dog sitting on her
bed to me that is him who was in her
room but she is like a an illusion you
know it's like almost like a dream or a
nightmare and everybody told me to cut
that out like all the important men came
into the editing room and we're like
we're gonna cut out the dog so I called
her in the bathroom because she was in
London shooting her TV show and I was
calling her blech they wanted to let the
dog go and she was very supportive but
we thought well okay let's listen to
them not be too rebellious about it so I
let it go and then and then a week later
I was like no no the dog has got to go
back into it and then I had to like sort
of form an army of people that would
support me
so now the dog is in the movie I let it
go it was out it was team Duberman yeah
well you know it's interesting because
some people lose that battle especially
on their first film I know you know yeah
did you have it was it was an easy
didn't it was very tough very emotional
of like fights you know a discussion
discussion but I do think we're very
blessed again to live in a country where
as a director especially if you make
like a low-budget art house movie like
this you are allowed to to to you know
be in control but I did feel like you
have to really really know what you want
because otherwise of course is
especially because I'm a first-time
director you are also very much
impressed by everybody else who has so
much experience so to go back and to
really go into that room say no I'm
gonna keep the dog it's really hard it's
really hard because people will say
things like well then this and this is
gonna happen or then you know nobody
will like your movie or stuff like that
completely and I'm still happy because
it's still people yesterday after the
screening also somebody made a remark
about it so it's still a little bit
confessional the dog in there but I like
it I'm very curious I'm a big fan of
your work
and I'm curious how do you do you look
like a pre shooting ritual do you like
how do you typically work on set because
I've spoken to so many actors that talk
about how they need silence and others
like to listen to music and others like
to do certain things I'm just curious
well I'm a mm-hmm I prepare by just
learning my lines and so that but I
never learned them well enough like I
always sort of keep keep some sort of
stress around around it so that I feel
like I'm not 100% sure what to do and
and I sort of thrive on that so I I like
that sort of it's like a writer who
writes it you know has deadlines writing
you know does a deadline writing they
could can only writes when when there's
like five minutes left so I on that sort
of stress not per se healthy but that
sort of fits my my way i I do prepare in
my head it's all very intellectual like
there's a lot of stuff happening in my
head beforehand and then I just want to
be on set and feel completely free so at
least I have thought about it a thousand
times and then I just go but I've
sometimes tell this story about I had to
do play once where I played that my
father had died and it was I don't know
half an hour before the premiere and
some guy came up to me backstage and
said and I was just joking and I was
just laughing and having fun with people
and actors behind the stage and the guy
said well why you know you're gonna do a
really important strong serious role now
like why are you not prepared why are
you not in the corner sitting
concentrating and I was like ah yeah oh
yeah maybe I should
oh yeah of course that's what actors do
I could suppose I should be
concentrating and I went and I retreated
and I've just said somewhere in a corner
and I sit there for five minutes I was
like now that's enough for me I can't do
this I it's when the curtains open it's
when someone calls action that's when I
when my motor goes I don't know how to
explain it
sure it's a very long story for very
short no no the only thing I've learned
about from doing this for a very long
time is that there's no right answer
that everyone needs to know what they're
comfortable with and it also depends how
you feel on the day if it depends on
what you have to do I mean if you have
to open a door I mean I can do card
tricks just before but of course if I
have to
that I'm gonna kill myself yes that's a
bit different of course that I'm not
gonna be joking maybe but yeah it all
depends
so you're getting ready to film this and
I'm what's the day do you you're looking
at the schedule you're looking at the
script is there anything that you making
you say well it's gonna be a really
challenging day oh yeah
well definitely in this film there was
many of those very very intense scenes
where the challenge is then to because
it's so such rough emotions that you
can't just you can't just act that you
just have to go out there go to that
place because it gets really ugly if you
don't if you don't stay true to that
feeling because otherwise it's really
difficult to watch it's it's fake it's
sort of so I felt like there was
definitely a few scenes where I just had
to completely turn myself upside down
and inside out and have people look
straight through me and it was yeah very
it's very vulnerable and there were days
where I just had a lot of lines and I
was like I need to be prepared there's a
time
no not prepared but you know I need to
really be focused because it's it's it's
very on the millimeter work kind of if
you know what I mean really when you do
scene yeah oh I do this [ __ ] all the
time I mean this is this is my side job
you know what I mean you've seen me in a
lot of movies you just don't realize it
so you guys are a part of the Toronto
Film Festival for both of you I mean
this is my favorite festival I love this
place what does it mean for both of you
to actually premiere here Lots because
of course we're so honored when we heard
that we were invited we I remember I was
on vacation I really screamed I was so
happy because yeah I mean I'd know the
city is great but the festival's really
really nice and everybody you already
were here before as an actress but
everybody told me that the audience is
so great that they're really movie
lovers and we very much experienced that
yesterday I think with the questions we
enjoyed the most of everything to do the
Q&A after because that's the only way to
find out what you know what
audience members thought or what their
analysis is or how they experience
there's no we we I think this is a great
great festival people are so primal in
their reactions that's why so wanted to
see the screening you can you know if
something something scary they'll be
like oh you can actually hear their
thoughts it's great because in in Europe
and especially Northern Europe our
reactions are quite reserved even though
we're you know we can be direct and we
can be blunt but sometimes in the way we
express our feelings it can be a bit
sort of you never really know sure and
that's in North America it's a
completely different story well it's a
it's also a completely different story
if you see a screening with like a lot
of press it's a little sometimes it can
be a little more quiet but I if I'm not
mistaken I believe yesterday you guys
something announced that you guys are
adopting or it's got the rights to a
world war two book so it was it timed
for yesterday or just sort of came out
yesterday
no it we did a lot of interviews of
course for the movie and then and we we
are already in the process of getting
these rights for some time because a lot
of people wanted these rights really you
know was a whole process to get them and
we're very proud and very honored that
it now we succeeded in optioning the
rights we should actually mention what
the title is and what it's about so it's
called the highness and it's a novel or
a book about a whirlpool world war two
about two sisters Jewish sisters and
it's a beautiful book and it's written
by a woman in Holland and the way it
happened was like this she moved into a
villa and now in contemporary time
outside of Amsterdam beautiful villa in
the woods and she started to grow them
to Highness called the Highness and she
started to renovate that place together
with her husband and then suddenly she
started to find all these things behind
walls under the floor clothing bits of
music that paper written music on it and
stuff like that and he's like what's
going on here and then that's how she
discovered this story of these two
sisters and so that's it's an incredible
story and we're very proud and now we're
only beginning to sort of you know take
it to another level
and make it into something I completely
understand so it's basically very early
days super early days I get it
my last few things for you a little bit
more fun if you will if you guys could
guess star do you watch any TV oh yes
okay so if you could guest direct a TV
show right now what what TV show the
same thing euphoria yeah okay I also
think it needs more female directors by
the way although it's totally created by
a guy I think it's the most incredible I
was gonna say a beautiful thing I think
the right answer is
everything should be 50/50 cool I agree
with you yeah I mean it's the right way
to go what movie have you seen the most
Tootsie the piano teacher by Hanukkah
have you guys ever been to Disneyland
yep
no do you have a favorite ride at
Disneyland I don't like this Neil and I
think it's like it's like Las Vegas for
kids it's like and also for adults
sorry well Disney and all your comics
and it's so beautiful but I mean and I
have a son so I might you might see me
there at some point but I think it's
hell on earth right I think if you go
there and you have like some sort of a
way to get to the front of the line
easier it's a different experience I
guess I guess yes but III get I don't
like big groups of people anyway and
these puppets that come up to you and is
there anything that you collect yep yeah
bum be in you know bum be you say the
little statues of Bambi sure or anything
of Bambi Disney exactly oh my god choirs
yeah I'm a hoarder I collect a lot of
things mostly [ __ ] like I have a lot of
shits and small things I like wart not
wardrobes and robes like bathrobes Oh
many of bathrobes I don't know do you
steal them do you steal them from hotels
no I have stolen a sheet just one or two
it might in my time what was the last
thing
guys were really obsessed with like a
book a movie a performance anything I'm
really obsessed by how do you pronounce
it properly you're not if you're now you
make I could have said it a second ago
and now of like you're for it I'm solely
obsessed I'm like googling I'm like I
want to see now the israelian version
that it is based on and I'm like I
cannot it's for me it's yeah it's
everything I'm really obsessed with it
it's so funny because yesterday the
writer of that show know where xyron
something he was he was supposed to be
here but he got sick because he was here
they were coming in for a film called
incitement which is this Israeli movie
about the assassination he was the
original the original writer probably
think I don't know if he was the
original creator or if he was the one
who created and he's also doing the
American version and I didn't get to
talk to him so but he was supposed to
come in fYI you could stalk I mean he's
around here I'm gonna stalk him yeah
definitely today I'm gonna go and stalk
him right now what was the last thing
you were obsessed with Wow okay okay
let's skip personal thing if I'd skip
personal [ __ ] I would say I can only
think of TV shows now but yeah I was
really obsessed with breaking bears yeah
what would you be in a while but you
know there's a Breaking Bad movie coming
out next month yeah you know what
not your thoria but is there what other
TV show have you watched all the way
through more than once the wire watch
three times
everything do you have a favorite season
three the office the English one the
British one got it
do you own any movie or TV show props do
you mean things that we did as actresses
ourselves no it could also be the source
that you had in all the Bambi's I
collect I collect them mostly from sets
because every art person will always
think like oh they this this woman has a
Bambi statue that's that's how I started
because I thought it was ridiculous that
they were in every room of every person
I played the character is it true yeah
there's always a little bit
somewhere now I have to be sure like a
writer in your contract
maybe she puts it in there I mean
seriously that could explain a lot you
keep anything because you have my
thermal underwear from the king of
Thrones that's yeah you can buy it
anywhere but I just
yeah stole some but you know liam
Cunningham he is a whole Museum at his
house stuff that he took that he
liberated right exactly
by the way if I if I worked on a show
like that I would liberate or borrow
plenty of things with every intention of
bringing it back exactly I mean 100
percent but my last question for you
guys do you remember what it was when
you were younger that actually maybe
flip the switch in your brain about like
wow I want to want to do this I want to
work in movies or one of the same man
same answer Annie
really yes and did you guys Daddy
Warbucks did it he did it he [ __ ] it
off it's all his fault that we are
sitting here with you right now was it
was it which version of Annie the
original I mean Queen the movie okay we
were six or something
oh you're classics right listen I know
exactly the movie I can I can see
everything about it that was your old
rut Brenner no it was Eileen Queen and
Daddy Warbucks was and what's your name
Carol Burnett yes yes you know Reese can
actually she won't do it because I asked
her before but she can actually actually
do like all the songs with props she
will get some props and she will do it
right now but maybe if we give her money
she lent yeah really seriously I'm not
gonna ask you to do she won't but no no
but that's amazing well mostly because
you probably can do the whole movie and
most people can like quote a line or two
from a film you know like but apparently
we're talking sue do you have the poster
on the wall no I wish though I did I did
for some time I don't have it anymore
I did I mean do you guys have a
production office no no that's sir home
I was gonna say have you had a
production office that should be the
poster I kind of waits to decorate our
production office let's get a production
office just to get the poster up I mean
this is like a no-brainer to me though
because if people ask you like this is
what got us into doing what we're doing
right now yes you know what I mean like
this is the note this is the thing you
know you need to also get one maybe with
autographs on it you need to go full
force okay let's do that
that's a great idea this is what I'm
here for and this is why I got paid
today listen thank you so much for
coming in today
Congrats on your movie for real I'm so
happy for you guys being part of the
Toronto Film Festival and good luck with
everything in the future thank you so
much it was very lovely conversation
thank you hopefully it was not painful